what's up everybody Welcome to the 22nd
ssit learn with python for machine
learning with our investing example
using a support Vector machine or
otherwise supervised learning tutorial
video anyway moving on uh in our last
video what we did was we pulled this
Yahoo finance you know current data and
we want to make a prediction based on
this data and maybe find some stocks
that we're interested in investing in so
with that uh we've got the data already
pulled as in the last video and now what
we're ready to do is move um forward and
actually kind of build a data set now on
that data our most recent data set was
this one right here from machine
learning video
18 uh so we're going to go ahe and take
that I'm going to do a control a contrl
C I'm going bring it over here crl a
contrl v
boom again you might want to save that
uh yaho polling uh cuz you could
actually in theory run that script daily
monthly yearly whatever ever so here we
have uh the building script and now what
we need to do is actually build uh
modify this script a little bit you know
my favorite thing to do uh modify this
slightly to handle the new format of or
the new I guess uh formatting of the
data I'm already breaking the new format
of the data basically right now it's not
it's in a different kind of directory
and
stuff and then we also we can't get like
the stock prices from year right we we
can't see in the future otherwise we
wouldn't be doing machine learning we
would just be investing so yeah we got
to account for all that stuff so with
that let's get
started uh so first we're going to go
ahead and we don't really need this path
bar
anymore uh we could call this
forward and uh that'll be that we'll
scroll down here we don't need either of
these anymore so just comment those out
and if you don't know how I'm doing that
again uh you just highlight alt three
and it comments them all out moving on
we don't need anything about this
current stock price or the current data
frame that's irrelevant to our uh
interest we also don't need this ticker
list irrelevant yet again but we do now
need a file list and we'll call this
file list equal to the os. liser and we
want to list the contents of the
directory for word because that is where
I stored all of my uh content so my the
stuff that we just pulled for our
forward um you know real time I suppose
um investing is in this directory
forward and we've got all these files
here so that's where the files are and
we want to access them and each file is
its own little ticker so that's our file
list now what we're going to say is for
each dur in I don't really want to
change that but for each dur in uh file
list what do we want to do and actually
I do want to change that that's going to
bother me so what we can do is we can go
contrl C to copy that contrl H which is
the find and replace we'll say each dur
we want to replace that with uh each
file because that's exactly what it is
replace all and that's that okay that
was going to bother me too much so for
each file in file list each file equals
os. list uh list d That's well basically
all this stuff is unnecessary actually
so we will just comment that out and in
fact I'm actually going to delete this
stuff it's just not necessary and it's
ugly to have a bunch of comments and now
instead we're going to just say ticker
equals each uh
file
doit by do HTML and we want the zeroth
or the left side of that and that will
be the ticker boom dun next we have uh I
was going to print ticker but n uh we're
going to say the full full file path
equals uh
forward
slash plus each uncore uh
file and that's our full file path and
then we're going to say the source and
the source is basically the source code
right so Source equals open full file
path uh with the intention to
read
and might actually not be
n whatever we'll continue on with the
intention to read and then do read uh
that's a little redundant though that's
okay okay so that's our source now oh uh
we can leave that I suppose that's
probably also redundant but that's
okay
um this is all
fine uh the date stamp we can get that
we don't really need to
though
um yeah basically all we need is we'll
just comment this out uh or I'm sorry
hold on hold everybody just wait a
second what is
happening so we need
this we don't want four file we
basically
want so this is two tabs over this is
where my brain breaks every freaking
time guys I'm sorry I apologize a weak
brain moving down we're trying to find
this except where is it that's this one
okay that's a lot okay
so uh all the way up to this now you can
press control and the opening square
brackets two tab over there
uh
okay uh that's embarrassing anyway so
all we need are the values we don't care
about anything else right we don't care
about we we do want the ticker right we
need this and this but then when it
comes to the rest of this stuff we just
need the values we don't need any
freaking thing else so we can actually
get rid of the Gathering of the S&P 500
stuff the stock stuff all the way down
to and even this stuff all the way down
to right before we do the not available
calculations so all of that boom delete
not
necessary accept okay and this try can
remain I think we I think we might do
this without any errors guys I'm excited
I'm excited okay so this is where we're
probably going to get our errors but uh
we'll handle it so date we just don't
care right the date is the date of the
poll so we'll know always what the date
is so I'm going to go ahead and copy
this we don't care about the Unix we do
care about the ticker we don't care
about the price we don't care about the
percentage change the S&P 500 nonsense
don't care don't care so all the way
down to basically distance from the
beginning to all the way down to
distance besides ticker just a bunch of
not availables okay and then
finally status again not available we
just don't care uh about that because
we're not we're not provy to that
information at this point now finally DF
to CSV instead of this nonsense we were
going to we're going to call this
forward uncore sample. CSV but we're
going to say
nocore na or is this with na first we'll
do no na right that's what we have right
here and and then we'll do with an a uh
and then finally key stats we called
this uh what did we call this
forward
forward so
forward save run it come on man we got
this no errors let's do it no one wants
to see these errors should be pretty
fast it's there okay so it says it's
done let's check it let's check it pull
this up
here what are you
doing here it
is well it's 120 kilobytes that might be
right pull this bad boy right on
over um okay so we see some not
availables but that's totally fine
because those are the ones that we we
slapped in
uh so let's good let's go ahead and save
one now with not available so no God
can't believe we made it this far guys
this is a good thing with na now we
allow up to
15 um and just for the record these not
availables don't affect this right this
is called first and then we input our
own not availables uh so that one and
we'll run one more here and that should
this will might take a little long well
no it shouldn't take really that much
longer um yeah yeah this video is
hitting 10 minutes so I'll probably cut
off this one as well uh and in the next
video we'll actually um run the tests
against this one but let's go ahead and
check this file slightly larger but not
by
much Okay so we've got that and now I
want to talk about moving into the for
uh you know moving forward moving into
the
forward so in the next video we've got
this data set and then what we'll do is
we'll train on the previous data set
then we'll call upon this data set after
we you know we've got we got the
training in memory and then we'll call
upon this data set and then we'll kind
of predict only based on this data set
so really we can train on the entire
previous data set and then we can call
upon this data set and make some
predictions so that's what we we'll do
and uh we might find that we either get
too many or too few uh predictions if we
get too few that's okay in theory you
shouldn't get a new prediction every day
but also in theory we should be we
should get uh say our prediction is um
Apple okay our prediction for Apple
should not I mean every day we should be
getting Apple if we have like a bunch of
days where we're not getting Apple
predicted then we shouldn't be in Apple
so anyway uh that's that so uh and that
might actually be a way of moving
forward as far as the stop loss is
concerned Al like I mentioned before
it's not like stop loss in in terms of
price it's really stop- loss in terms of
you know fundamental features of these
companies so if you know if let's say 4
weeks goes by and given the features it
says hey this is still not a good
investment then we can get out we don't
necessarily have to wait until the full
year is up something like that anyway uh
let's hop to the next video so stay
tuned for that if you have any questions
or comments on this video please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next
[Music]
time